russia has invaded ukraine and many are
calling this an illegal war of
aggression but what does it mean for a
war to be illegal what does
international law mean in this context
and what is even international law
itself because the recent russian
invasion of ukraine has shocked and
horrified people all around the world
almost every nation has condemned the
invasion many calling it an illegal war
even traditionally neutral countries
like switzerland and sweden have joined
in economic sanctions against russia and
the secretary general of the united
nations concluded that russia's invasion
of ukraine violated international law
saying quote it is wrong it is against
the united nations charter it is
unacceptable the united nations charter
which has been affirmed by 193 member
states says that countries should not
invade each other but what happens next
comes down to this who if anyone has the
authority to enforce international law
and how are you going to stop an
invading force
[Music]
law professor lewis henkin who is
credited with founding the study of
human rights law famously wrote the
quote almost all nations observe almost
all principles of international law and
almost all of their obligations almost
all the time hankins observation was
that in the modern world most countries
agree on the general standards of
international conduct however the
troubles arise because of the word
almost
what about when nations don't agree with
international standards of conduct or
just simply don't observe them do these
international standards have the force
of law
does the international community have
the ability to enforce its standards of
conduct well today we're going to talk
about international law what it is what
it isn't and what happens next in
ukraine but for some background on
russian and ukrainian history now this
is a very complicated subject i'm only
going to scratch the surface but i think
this will be helpful from 1922 until
1991 ukraine was a member of the soviet
union but in 1991 it declared its
independence and became its own
sovereign state in 2004 the orange
revolution led to annulling a
presidential election which was claimed
to be marred by massive corruption voter
intimidation and electoral fraud new
elections were held in 2005 that
eventually led to viktor dushenko
beating the russian-backed victor
yanukovich but janukovic eventually
succeeded in the 2010 election but in
2013 the ukrainian people launched a
protest movement against the corrupt
pro-russian president viktor yanukovych
who was seen as being backed by russian
billionaires who were hostile to nato
not to make this about the united states
but coincidentally during this era
donald trump's campaign manager paul
manafort spent 10 years as one of
yanukovich's advisors of course in 2020
president trump was impeached by the
house after he put on hold 391 million
dollars in congressionally approved
military aid to ukraine but in 2013
ukraine's government was about to sign
an agreement establishing closer ties
with europe but yanukovych backed out
one week before the agreement was to be
signed instead he announced that ukraine
would build a stronger relationship with
russia this announcement reneged on a
campaign promise and yanukovich's
popularity plummeted and after the
euromaidan protest yanakovic fled to
russia and ukraine elected a pro-western
government and in 2014 russia tried to
hack ukraine's central election
commission so that it would present a
far-right candidate who in fact got less
than one percent of the vote as the
winner as historian tim snyder
documented the hack failed but russian
media had been prepared for its success
and russian television went on air with
falsified documents even digital images
that matched what the hack was supposed
to produce when the election gambit
failed russia invaded ukraine and
annexed the territory of crimea and in
2019 former comedian vlodimir zielinski
who on tv played a history teacher who
ran on an anti-corruption platform and
eventually became the president of
ukraine
ran on an anti-corruption platform and
became the president of ukraine and of
course prior to this most recent
invasion zielinski was famous in the
united states for having what everyone
called a perfect phone call with former
president donald trump just an
absolutely perfect phone call then in
february of 2022 russian president
vladimir putin launched a full-scale war
on ukraine claiming that he needed to
eliminate nazism in ukraine and that he
was defending the people of the donbus
regions of ukraine the international
community recognized that donbass like
crimea is part of ukraine so the
question is is this an illegal war and
what does it even mean to be an illegal
war under international law well i'm
sorry to tell you it probably doesn't
mean all that much so the phrase
international law is a bit of a misnomer
because international law isn't really
binding in the way that american laws
generally are in america the primary
sources of law are the us constitution
laws enacted by congress rules
promulgated by federal agencies state
constitutions laws enacted by state
legislatures rules promulgated by state
agencies and city or county charters and
local laws and as you can see there's
generally a hierarchy to these laws
statutes and rules can't contradict a
higher source of law for example the us
constitution is generally at the top of
that list and a state law or state
constitution that contradicts the
federal constitution where state law is
supreme is considered void but in
contrast there isn't really an
international hierarchy of law sovereign
nations may agree on general principles
of conduct but there isn't a body of
international law that is superior to
their own national laws so the first
thing you need to know about
international law is that everything is
dependent on the individual states and
as you can imagine individual sovereign
nations are incredibly reluctant to give
up any of their autonomy and to subject
themselves to the potential whims of
other countries the united states is no
exception to this
so what do we mean when we talk about
international law well the most
important sources of international law
are customary international law derived
from practice of the states treaties
between the states and general
principles of law recognized by
civilized nations now the oldest source
of what we call international law tends
to be customary international law and
this doesn't really have a written
source like a criminal code instead it's
more like english common law since it's
made up of unwritten rules that are
derived from custom and practice a rule
of customary law has two elements first
there has to be widespread and
consistent state practice the practice
must be by the government but must also
be recognized by the state's courts and
parliaments and second there has to be
what's called a pineal juris which is
the state's belief that it has a legal
obligation what's an example of
customary international law well
diplomatic immunity for example
diplomatic immunity is a principle that
gives certain foreign government
officials the right to save passage
through other countries guaranteeing the
diplomat cannot be sued or arrested for
violating the host country's law this
principle of diplomatic immunity is one
of the oldest elements of foreign
relations observed in ancient greece and
rome
sometimes now prior to world war ii
countries recognize diplomatic immunity
based simply on precedent but after
world war ii diplomatic community was
embedded in a number of international
conventions and today all countries
agree that diplomats have diplomatic
immunity although they can be expelled
from their host countries for violating
the law then we can talk about treaties
treaties are a second source of
international law an international
treaty is a written agreement between
international law subjects reflecting
their consent to the creation alteration
or termination
of their rights and obligations treaties
may also be called agreements
conventions or protocols now a treaty is
not the same thing as a law a treaty is
a source of an obligation under the law
and treaties are only binding on states
which agree to become parties to them so
there is no international tribunal or
government that can force any sovereign
nation to become a party to a treaty
against that nation's will and so if
there's no government or court that can
compel states to join or comply with the
treaty
why are treaties binding at all well
generally because of a customary
principle of international law called
pacta cervada which is latin for
agreements must be kept in i greatly
apologize for all of my mispronounced
latin throughout this entire video as it
turns out it's really hard to speak a
dead language now all states recognize
that they are bound by the agreements
that they make and therefore they are
obligated to honor their treaties but
sometimes a treaty will memorialize a
principle of customary law in essence
codifying a general understanding
between nations for example the 1969
vienna convention on the law of treaties
codified the basic customary principles
governing international treaties the
vienna convention is known as the treaty
on treaty and in the us for example a
treaty only becomes binding if congress
agrees that it should become binding and
effectively the law of the united states
so again it's about the consent of the
governed and if a country wants to back
out of a treaty there's effectively
nothing that any other country can do
but then that takes us to general
principles of civilized nations these
are general principles of fairness and
justice which are applied universally in
legal systems around the world and
although that sounds pretty sweeping in
reality these principles are pretty much
gap fillers when there's a dispute and
there is no provision in an
international treaty or statute or any
recognized customary principle of
international law the general principles
of law can be used to fill the gaps an
example of that would be the admission
of indirect evidence
in 1949 an international court of
justice decision addressed whether
albania had civil liability for the
mining of the corfu channel and
subsequent damage to two british naval
vessels the court ruled that the uk
could establish the knowledge and
responsibility of albania for laying
mines in the water through indirect
evidence since indirect evidence is
admitted in basically all systems of law
then of course there are other sort of
miscellaneous sources of international
law that may help resolve international
disputes you can look to court decisions
writings by international lawyers and
actions taken by the united nations and
its many organs but you can imagine that
if the prior sources of international
law aren't binding these certainly are
not going to have that much of a
presidential effect now i'm sure many
people are watching this video and
screaming at the screen what about the
united nations well the united nations
was established after world war ii to
provide a formal way for nations of the
world to communicate and resolve
disputes the charter of the united
nations is an international treaty that
commits member states to settle their
disputes by peaceful means many people
have the mistaken impression though that
the un general assembly is the
government of the whole world however
the united nations general assembly has
no power to legislate for the
international community its resolutions
are not legally binding the general
assembly cannot enact international laws
and then force member states to submit
to its authority u.n resolutions do
influence international relations but
they're not the equivalent of laws and
statutes so that's the united nations
general assembly but what about the un
security council and in fact the u.n
security council is the only
international body that has the power to
make binding decisions on all nations
the council has 15 members the five
permanent members are china france
russia the united kingdom and the united
states and it also has 10 non-permanent
members whose terms run for two years
each member has one vote and in 2022 the
temporary members of the security
council are the united arab emirates
albania brazil gabon ghana india ireland
kenya mexico and norway the five
permanent members all have veto power
over all u.n security council matters
and under the charter of the united
nations all member states are obligated
to comply with council decisions
therefore decisions by the u.n security
council are considered legally binding
quote under chapter 7 the council can
take measures to enforce its decisions
and ensure that mandates are fulfilled
the security council can impose economic
sanctions or order an arms embargo and
on rare occasions the council has
authorized member states to use all
necessary means including collective
military action to see that its
decisions are carried out all member
states are obligated under the u.n
charter to carry out the security
council's decision now although the
world is remarkably united about
russia's war against ukraine it will
still be difficult if not impossible for
the security council to take direct
action against russia most security
council decisions require a majority of
the nine members plus consent of all
five permanent member states russia a
permanent member vetoed a council
resolution condemning its attack on
ukraine china and india and the united
arab emirates abstained from that vote
but you can imagine that as long as
russia is a member of the un security
council no resolution is going to pass
though i will say there is an
interesting legal movement gaining some
traction which says that russia is in
fact not a member of the un security
council effectively the argument goes
like this the original member of the un
security council was the soviet union
and the soviet union collapsed though it
was succeeded by the russian federation
russia just assumed that it took over
the spot that was originally created for
the ussr so some argue that without
formalizing this relationship with
russia russia does not hold the seat
that the former soviet union held on the
security council this seems a little bit
far-fetched but we'll see if it gains
traction in the future but let's take a
moment to talk about the use of force
under international law after the
devastation of two world wars the united
nations was born the u.n charter
established a prohibition on the use of
force to resolve disputes among states
article 2 section 4 of the charter bans
the threat or use of force one against
the territorial integrity of a state to
against the political independence of a
state and three in any other manner
inconsistent with the purposes of the un
now that said there are two exceptions
to the prohibition on the use of force
the security council can use force on
behalf of the u.n to maintain peace and
security a member state can also use
self-defense to repel an armed attack
chapter 7 of the u.n charter establishes
that force may be used to keep the peace
if the security council determines that
there is the existence of a threat to
the peace a breach of the peace or an
act of aggression and efforts to address
the matter using measures short of force
have failed or would be futile now in
the early days of the u.n the charter
suggested that all member states would
make their military resources
collectively available to the security
council to use to stop wars but this is
effectively never materialized and as a
result when the council needs a
peacekeeping force willing states
volunteer their personnel
putin tried to take advantage of this
exception by declaring that his forces
were a peacekeeping force and former
president trump thought this was a great
idea and suggested that the u.s should
invade mexico with fake peacekeeping
forces as well of course this is not
what peacekeeping means under the u.n
charter as one source put it the
security council takes the lead in
determining the existence of a threat to
the peace or an act of aggression it
calls upon the parties to a dispute to
settle it by peaceful means and
recommends methods of adjustment or
terms of settlement under chapter 7 of
the un charter the security council can
take enforcement measures to maintain or
restore international peace and security
such measures range from economic
sanctions to international military
action the council also establishes u.n
peacekeeping operations and special
political missions now additionally
article 51 of the u.n charter provides
for self-defense
nothing in the present charter shall
impair the inherent right of individual
or collective self-defense if an armed
attack occurs against a member of the
united nations until the security
council has taken measures necessary to
maintain international peace and
security a sovereign nation's right of
self-defense predates international
organizations and it's one of the
fundamental principles of state
sovereignty and as part of this right
nations can rescue their own citizens
who are trapped or being held in another
country but a nation can't claim it's
merely protecting its own citizens if
its real aim is to overthrow a foreign
government now russian president putin
said that people in the donbass
republics sought russia's help and that
qualifies as self-defense but article 51
applies to states not to individuals so
as of now russia is the only state that
has recognized the two donbass republics
as their own nations though this claim
appears to be pretext for invasion and
although putin claims that the
ukrainians are committing genocide in
the donbus this also appears to be a
pretext as well and russia also claims
that ukraine is the aggressor here but
even after the invasion of crimea
ukraine did not invade or really even
threaten russia
so is the war in ukraine illegal under
international law well yes but the
principle that war is illegal is only as
strong as the international community's
willingness to intervene in the conflict
and the first modern attempt to make war
illegal was in 1928 when the u.s and
france created the kellogg-briand pact
where dozens of countries joined the
treaty which called on nations to settle
their disputes peacefully
this treaty was only as good as its
members commitment to it and of course
the pact meant nothing when world war ii
erupted a decade later the world tried
again in 1949 with the geneva
conventions the geneva conventions
govern how civilians prisoners of war
and soldiers are treated you've probably
heard that the geneva conventions
prohibit nations from torturing people
or using torture to extract information
and effectively all nations have joined
the geneva conventions but these
treaties only govern how people are
treated during war they don't say
anything about the legality of the war
itself and even though the security
council actions are said to be binding
they're only binding if the council
actually chooses to enforce them for
example the iran-iraq war in the 1980s
clearly violated the laws of war but the
security council took no steps to
intervene and then finally perhaps most
importantly there is the international
criminal court now the icc is an
independent judicial institution that
was established in 2002 it is empowered
to investigate and prosecute war crimes
crimes against humanity genocide and the
crime of aggression 123 countries are
icc members which means that these
countries have given the icc the
authority to investigate and prosecute
crimes committed by their nations or by
anyone on their territory the icc
doesn't have the power over countries
that aren't a party to the treaty
however and the u.s for example did not
join the icc president clinton signed
the rome statute the treaty authorizing
the icc but the senate wouldn't ratify
it and president george w bush then
unsigned the treaty informing the u.n
that america did not recognize any
obligations under the icc nevertheless
u.s citizens can still be prosecuted for
committing more crimes if it happens in
a territory that is an icc member
afghanistan for example is a party to
the icc and can request that the icc
investigate americans for committing war
crimes but at the same time the icc
cannot override the laws of any
sovereign nation it only exercises its
jurisdiction when a country is either
unwilling or genuinely unable to
investigate and prosecute war crimes and
of course countries are free to
prosecute war crimes in their own courts
but that being said neither russia nor
ukraine have signed or adopted the rome
treaty and are not members of the icc so
russia cannot be prosecuted for the
crime of aggression however in 2014
after russia annexed crimea ukraine
submitted a declaration giving the icc
jurisdiction for crimes committed any
time on his property after february
2014. so ukraine can ask that icc
prosecutors open a full investigation
into russia's actions
now i know when we cover international
law it often feels like there's nothing
that we can do but that's not true and
in fact if you'd like to do some good
for this world especially regarding
ukraine i'd recommend tab for cause
which is helpfully sponsoring this video
now tab for cause lets you raise money
for charity just by opening tabs and
browsing the internet which we were
probably gonna do anyway and in fact tab
for a cause responded to your request
and they have an entire ukraine specific
page geared towards providing essential
services and supplies to ukrainian
families and in fact save the children
has been providing ongoing humanitarian
aid in ukraine since 2014 and will
continue to support families even if
fingers crossed the conflict ends soon
now tab for a cause is a google chrome
extension that allows you to pick the
charity of your choice and then every
time you open up a new tab instead of
displaying a blank page it displays a
beautiful new customized tab with a
couple of tiny ads now the money that
you generate through those open pages is
then donated to your charity tab for a
cause has partnered with save the
children which is mobilizing now for the
ukrainian people and tab for a cause
finances are completely transparent you
can see for yourself how much money
they've raised every quarter and where
that money has gone and believe it or
not the legal eagles the people like you
who are watching my videos have already
raised over 35 000 alone for charity
just by opening tabs and i'm really
thankful for that so all you have to do
is click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description and
install the chrome extension that's it
every page you open will create revenue
that goes to charity and it's completely
free
tap for caused users like you have
raised millions of dollars and it's the
easiest possible way to donate to
charity so just click on the link below
and download the extension and do some
good by doing what you were going to do
anyway so click on that link or i'll see
you in court